ma ma com'è possibile
bubi adesso non messa nuova alla messa
nuova vediamo se passa ma cosa ho fatto
adesso è pubblica adesso si è pubblicata
dovevamo vincere mentre nel mentre
abbiamo vinto ragazzi questa cosa
assurda
vediamo adesso è tornata on line di chi
siamo
ci risiamo sud e ci sia ma cosa è
successo ma io non lo so ordinaria
amministrazione basi che adesso poi rai
dare la gente su youtube
ma dai dopo quando quella roba
dell'altro sito che come per l'altra
sito dopo quando finiamo rai diamo
cerchiamo con le bimbo convento di
youtube nel se diamo insieme a tanti di
noi vediamo un bimbo che il 2 spettatori
vorrei dare in positivo nel senso
ripartiamo gente è certo è che le
bandiere non sapeva stare vicina
impazzito impazzito
la stacca attacca impazzite vabbè ma se
ride ora è positivo che la rai diventi
sempre come caccese per la roba tipo
come se dobbiamo rai darlo per me è il
nome che si da coloro che allora si sia
parlato ragazzi è no niente se sconnessa
la live
ma intanto stampa ma tanto senza un
motivo perché io non è che ho
schiacciato il tasto andava della cella
la juve continuava a dirmi che era in
esecuzione ma non andava
cioè se si è chiusa la so non aveva il
caffè siamo noi
è saltata fare anche così l'ho letto
tante no non so se mi ventola ma certo
che ti saluto caro e no e mi dispiace
che se perché si sono spezzati gli
ultimi 30 minuti di live che cacchio è
un peccato che era tutto tutto di fila o
scusa se grazie quindi niente va beh
facciamo finta di nulla
venti trenta secondi e metteremo non
elencati che fa brutto mamma mia che
cosa bella bella quando mi riescono se
così ogni caso sarà come lo controllata
ciao zio ci vediamo
francesca welcome idee per giorgio
canali ricordo ragazzi che potete
supportarci supportarci col tasto a bonn
antico sotto o abbonati ancora non si è
capito è la super chat e di fianco anche
con i super sic e se volete farci una
domanda insomma niente comunque non so
perché si sia interrotta la leve di
prima
non ho all'amico me non è la prima volta
che mi succede senza io faccio nulla non
saremo io ne ho peccato ancora ancora
ancora green grazie rilevano una serate
è per le z max press max non sono
pronunciati grazie quel comune pangrazio
caro virginia aver capito e giacomo gara
grazie mille molto bene ragazzo tanto
bene occhio che c'è il turbo che scusami
di levi scusarmi dai lati regalo un
mazzo di fiori
nello stesso roberto vecchi miti e
giacomo per chi si fosse con e adesso
stiamo giocando in 3d 3 che è un granché
diverso dalle 22 dove siamo rancati
diamante trejo step però qua siamo
mancati in platea in diamante due no
diamante loro quasi diamante due perché
era anche di altre culture sono diversi
dai due v2 cioè nel senso è proprio
molto più difficile
sono proprio due l'anti iphone dorate
diverso più difficile e ci stiamo
provando
non siamo andati male la tela abbiamo
vinta il 70 per cento alla fine no
quindi non mi chiamo erano turbo però va
bene bravi fatto una roba stranissima
emmanuele emanuele raia le quinte
giacomo ti terrò grazie al super speaker
caro number one fan si professa proprio
lui il fan numero uno con superficie
grazie caro stiamo sondare qui
dall'altra parere attivamente un
sorrentino
io lo metterei è che questa bruttissima
devi togliere forte bravo allora avo
roberto il pre l'upgrade al piergiorgio
grazie caro e sono andato io come un
bubble dove sembrano tu per attenzione
da di pietro per fare robe incredibili
mana tranche che ci sono da vamp atto a
lui contenuta troppo alta però
l'attenzione rubo turbo controllo perché
il ruvo turbo provochi meno non importa
il 7 si sono messi a volare questi brava
voto
thr o grazie mille per i super super
sticker hai un super sic è veramente
super questo è uno dei migliori del
match forse il migliore dell'anno per
ora non sono giudicate grande grazie
idee
è così che si gioca cacchio questo te lo
dedico caro grazie alla donazione
proprio piazza conte lo dedico visto
questo super sticker che è troppo bello
è esatto questo è un gol che si dedico
grazie a lei ha visti mangiare alla mia
panatta
grazie a tutti i ragazzi fatto tre gol a
partita perché non insegna due no non
pensavo che facesse sta roba che usi la
ottenere una fennec e ragazzi perché la
octane a un nel controllo è un pelo
meglio della fennec è visto un controllo
più di volare ha più senso che usi la
gola of tanks la fenech e questo è
l'unico motivo capito
this is the motivo io no ed esiste
motivo ma mi aspetto da preso era un
missile
così un missile terra aria fox antonio
welcome monte giacomo bazzani le caro
oddio avanti pato ora da 4 a 2
attenzione che questi possono
recuperarla che vita brutto th ros ei
super senso persino super super super
supporter oggi con super sic e grazie
mille caro davvero grazie a mirate
supporta se supero il supporto stavo
dicendo però sa effettivamente era tutto
talmente listi dire no ai games che
mentre pd non rischiare che rischiara
boris game welcome idee giacomo broschi
questa mia no che gol
sono veramente ragazzi dal 4 a 0 a 4 3
ragazzi non è bello è bello che ho detto
pure questo e mi ha fatto di hacker o
ancora come super speaker grazie alle
rai annunzia voi come giacomo caro
dettaglio minuto e ben david ha un
bacino grazie alla the nation attenzione
aspetta che controllo qua eccolo bella
ma un giro dello step che male è malato
pollici per sticker th rho comunque
grassini ma mano grazie quel compito e
giacomo garbin ha veramente super
supporter caro
grazie mille garo quante volte ho detto
che erogava caro arrivato il concetto
però questo tiro è veramente un tiro
caro niente dai takhar o la mette in
mezzo la notte non la metto neanche in
mezzo però c'è il tiro dello stesso
non potrò la nostra partita però gli ha
ricevuto un messaggio da mia madre che
va decifrato scusa ok bidone scatta la
pillola patenti o capitone è come mia
madre mi chiamava quando portavo antica
bene mettendo assieme senza dirmi nulla
che i video né scatola pillola patenti e
della voce allora ok bidone volete
scrivere all'agente segreto x6 bidone
euring è una cosa veramente strana un
inizio per titolare per una frase
ok stefano e gliela correttori in bidone
altri a pillole di socio e poi mamma mia
ma di file leggera scatta la pillola tre
patenti a caso allora se controlli nel
bidone c'è una scatola delle di pillole
che vicino alla patente b a che non
esiste ributtata fx grazie alla trazione
garone show grana di michael preston al
mega su tramite web cominciato allora
ancora un 10 minuti era che facciamo
perché scassata la rai prima davide per
quindi e giacomo che grazie mille
progetto zomba vediamo quanto stiamo
diamanti lavoro per mare diamond2 io
sono qua divisione iii mannaggia platino
tre giornate divisione 4 pattinato
divisione 1 io tra poco c'è fra poco
voglio dire a un po valgo diamante gigi
era legalità lenta non la metto perché
se no devo ridurre i canali switch a
recco tanto mancano 10 un quarto d'ora
chi sa caro ciao caro che la semina
donazioni grazzini si è passato oggi
grazie del mega supporto
noi facciamo di non so fin quanto
continui se facciamo io farei anche a
tipo 810 così almeno recupero quei
secondi in più e che sono ma vedi ma
vedi che quali ha fatto iniziare filippo
largamente giacomo caro bellissimo
bellissimo ci penso io
bravo è però rimasto creatura doveva
rimanere mi più attaccata alla macchina
bel gol
ilsinho poverello una bomba nucleare in
tutti i sensi che mina che l'uscita
barca miseria nella vela eyed peas enser
[Musica]
beh io da presa cosa ho fatto ora che
cos'ha fatto
perché per la donazione di riccò ricorda
che eravamo contro i francesi di essere
un casato e urlato quella cosa si ok
perchè mettete perché non lo posso dire
è che non c'è solo il mio caso manica
eccoli la gente guarda logico melo bump
a questo mister aiutiamo la mamma no da
bravo davide grazie mille della nation
caro grazie fratello gli ordinò alla
roba intanto e senso no non ero da
mangiare ragazzi ma domani però
specificare pure questo
ma dai tira fuori dal ultimi codice
allora per me la roba era vero è
un'altra guerra in pieno da cosa siamo
che bello questo e patapim e patapim e
patapam aspetta aspetta aspetta ma che
schifo faccio ragazzi e allora tutto che
è tutto tutto caso si si non la fate voi
un pò su ciò che riguarda d'ordine ogni
hamburger
ok hamburger oggi è oggi oggi sano ma
come
come fai a latina ma dovetti rocchette
certo la palla ha già entrare prima
questa sì sì chelsea si si si sono ci
sono mica vincerai tutti gli imballi asi
invece mica posso non posso ma non posso
vincerlo non posso brano marito stef a
spazzare bene ho capito magari se
qualcuno la tocca in mezzo potrebbe
essere una bell'azione e invece no ho
rischiato e dovevo tenerla la puoi fare
mamma mia se la toccavo meglio potrà
finire talenti importatrice la diga tira
niente vale vale per come si è già cosa
perché perché vale ancora lì in de
giacomo grazie gara bene dai poteva
diventare un bellissimo cross p abello
zio ha deciso che non ci fa bene io
provo a volare per non c'è nessuno
dietro però fatto proprio bene ho fatto
bene privato la nutella
oggi vi viaggio russa controlla che sa
come la sono attimo col gaby paesaggi
trujillo ti devo recare mettere tipo
quando sono set
l'hack è male mamma mia niente niente ma
non posso a no ma non posso o demolito
quello che stava in difesa guarda come
rimbalzo bravi come un uccellino compie
aggressivo celino ravetta aggressivo ma
che dico aquila
cenni no no no lo zio apre la coccinella
ancora peggio nella ii
ci prova sarà cucinato e fortunata fino
alla quindi potrebbe dare lamentino tipo
questo mega rimbalzano madonna due lisci
ragazzi non lo turbano turbano turbo è
finita è finita è perso è brutto non ci
credo non ci credo
e invece no è invece più in alto di
tutti
puoi tirare step rasoterra non c'è pure
però nessuna parte ciò che pensavo ci
fosse il terzo livello porta va bene
cosa bellissima questa scusate
all cioè broccoli e berlato nate proprio
loro mamma mia che la portano in
vittoria mamma mia che partita
incredibile proprio un water è rimasto a
napoli non ci arrivava a realizzarlo
bene almeno il roll per far finta di
provarci con tutte le sue energie vale
male grazie mille sisters però ripresa
tutti i all ag non tira mai madonna e
tutto questo sociali ordinarono anche un
gatto vuole non ci riesce
quanto gruppo da una di esse miliardi
cironte orribili sorrentino 41 50
secondi grande io entro in uno stato di
panico assurdo quando la palla mini gli
resta sopra il tettino non è tutto scusa
non capisco e soprattutto se poi corre
gente attorno in quel modo è ancora
peggio cercare io sono i giorni con il
coltello lisci con abbiamo perso solo le
partite del placement praticamente
esistiamo per vincendo tutte quelle dopo
è questa la cosa incredibile manca una
vittoria passo di 22 e ma se tipo 15enne
3 perse ma infatti c'è in nove meno
studena roba che abbiamo vinta una marea
effettivamente e questa l'abbiamo aperta
ragazza arrivando da sotto la porta all
odore di qualcosa di veramente buono
infatti questo non fa che cup accadono
partire io sorry sorry sorry sorry
monaco iones hai distrutto
si chiama è scritto lì hanno sì sì
infatti dovrà diventare penso sia
spagnolo è in spagnolo vuol dire la
stessa cosa io non l'ho presa
magari mi disse che sorgerebbe pixel per
l'entrata grazie alla faccia delle pixel
taglie dai no comparto non povero questo
partiremo questa mia napoli 1
l'ho toccata allo spirito non so come si
è visto malissimo sta ordinando
tamburini tutto ok ordinando ferdinando
la boria mamma mia che bel tiro fatto
grandissimo stefan è nota ai ragazzi no
no no no non è vero io non ho sentito
niente
non è chiaro anche la palla è rimasta lì
ferma come se non avessi nache toccata
bravissima partite 11 ragazzi ma uno va
recuperata la dieta la tep spa il
controllo e la thema che di controllare
di uno saltati non saltato attenzione da
palle li monaco yonex tocca la
bravissimo bravi tira di ai mammamia
attraversa che strano di appena successo
oggi come mai
ok forse cose niente un prodotto con
tale in mezzo come potevo attengono a
tengo dai mamma mia
abbiamo che abbiamo pressati li abbiamo
pressati come il pongo esorcizzato
esercitiamo la dieta infatti qualcosa
grazie a 3 mila spettatori la di smith a
che non niente ha posizionato a non so a
tremila abbonati
la dismettibili attraverso il gerardo
grazie alle donazioni ragazzino magari
ci metterei la firma guarda te li faccio
io 3000 bonami evento la notte per
stesso caldissimo che si prende la sua
ma con tre e krypi l'avatar di monaco
ionel mamani veramente e finch a tre
ragazzi e finch ha officiato penso ci
basta quelle già atene la porta
vai vai vai vai di dylan
così durante la cena dei tetti è quello
quello attenzione attenzione
no no goal ed ecco io guarda ero 20
centimetri più avanti niente questo è un
bel poster che la direzionata proprio
perfetta in centro non la potevo
togliere nascosta piena davanti alla
porta
abbiamo con la roccia che si stacca
elastico attenzione ecco e vabbè scusami
di non è solito dovrai tranquillo e
ancora tirare
mamma mia che per caso non c'era serata
alzavo di più
restiamo lì come prima i ragazzi vai vai
vai by step tutti quanti noi eravamo
andati in quel lato vai ce l'hai
no è una manna lontana occhio ragazzi
togliete è brutta per favore
nole no ma no a tutti che l'ha vista
nessuno che gioca questo gioco non ci
giocare ma nessuno
meno male preso palo raga ok siete voi e
io sì però non sono alte facendo capisco
non si capisce visto che però
dell'energia topini e mi sa di sì il
buon gioco più un gioco sia del mattino
siamo passati dal fraseggio del
barcellona al fratello di fraseggio
dell'albinoleffe anch'io dico sempre di
non f quando non so che magari
fortissima b non è perché social che
magari
f.to per i speck mai mai mai pressa
alpino adesso è super e spec attenzione
l'ho toccata a sei volte non entrata
bravo di chi si è fatto una madonna che
elastico che ho fatto c'è com'era
dovrebbero acquistare qua vacuità non
capitano guardalinee però secondo me
dopo questa si chiama ronaldinho dei
diritti morali etiche branzino euro to
fail alert con la bocca è nato perché
non capivo attenzione che il top
incredibile che potrebbe essere volo per
qualcuno che arriva a [ __ ] niente va
bene
becker il gol tra l'altro sto
arrotolando da 22 minuti bello e finch
atene www ma c'è anche le voci della
effe se volete utilizzarla voi abbonati
che molto più belle che ancora più
meglio della effe normale gli easy
andiamo via
corri corri con quella palla tiro io
fratelli
no dai facciamo un'altra volta aspetti
che sta attendendo lui madonna tutti i
lisci e allora non lo tocchiamo più l
giochiamo ti prego via bello pericolosa
vado io ragazzi non importa a vincerla
torna ap in difesa i miti mancata non ti
fa saltare 18 si sono un po il diavolo
della tasmania però ero quello cha va a
rubare il cuore va
niente dai speso oltre a 3 sul 38esimo
secondissimo finale va bene abbiamo
ancora tempo per il 4 per loro
attenzione andiamo attenzione però c'è
anche il mondo rosso che potrebbe essere
successo l'abbiamo fatto
sì sì sì è clamoroso c'era lui sono
andato in anticipo ma non è brutta bravi
madonna se per caso lo salta vi della
buona e potevi farcela attenzione
attenzione il dribbling dello step
niente training da chi demolito se
voleva me bello
potete fare l'ultima azione volendo
tirate tiro io ma lo coyotes la
controllo sezione tirate no mammamia
cavalino potresti dire viva le winx
certo che dico vi lambiva le vinse
grazie capitano nation e beccati sto col
cerone gol regala presa la presa
questa cosa non succede mai quando ci
siamo noi importa mai mai mai mai la
presa pazzesco regalano turbo tra la
placata usa mistero fingete di
migliarina spende tutti e due
spinge continuato a spingere questi
soffrono le spinte bravo la controllo
ok niente
vai perfetto con la verso il turbo
sicuro io non ho turbo la deve sei mai
veramente importa tono tiro non ebbero
di anticipato oggi occhio chiocchio eh
no ho sbagliato che va bene lo pescatore
male sempre tutto cat anch'io di nuovo
tutti con occhio tutto volto ragazzino
no turbo mai tutti siamo lì sono tutti
quanti no scusami bruschino chiave
vibrare la vita
che sfiga no abbiamo preso gol solo per
colpa più che altro quelli l'anno parata
all'inizio quello si è fatto una parata
pazzesca
porcaccia vacca io farei l'ultima perché
bisogna mai perdere così ma perdere cosa
vuoi fare l'ultima sempre di me lo
vediamo la scena dove vai proviamoci
bene per iron mike mamma battaglia ma
questa è vincevamo diventava mediamente
2 perché accetti acceso la divisione un
altro giocatore a nulla niente posto per
è andato in cosa secondo me diamanti due
comunque non so anch'io ho messo in vita
raga che palle ho sbagliato sbagliato
tranquilla strada si ricerca in corso mi
dice sì perché c'è questo pride i match
che sfiga maledetta maledizione era
rimasta lì la palla quello la parata ma
come ha fatto era rimasta di fermat
jotaro non ha fatto in tempo a leggere
scusami caro per ho letto il nome fa vi
doveste avere più iscritti pajero so
anche io ci sono così tante persone nel
mondo del pallone italiano accesi in
corso comunque non vidi più bravo non si
dicono le parolacce ma che scherzo
cancellato dall'utente la partita è
terminata ok ma vinta si accesso per
farci tempo abbia finto che una vittoria
c'erano ragazzi adesso sta facendo
l'accesso non so se vi sta accedendo
siamo al ces accesso accesso
sperimentato contenuti meno loro
desiderano fare o tra ricordi aperto era
posta per quello la dimensione solo che
tu come sempre 3 ricordi tutte a memoria
proprio parola per parola di pizza
manicomio hanno una fine molto dolorosa
non troppo ragazzi c'è un'apertura si
chiama harry harry potter e lo posso
dire
la scuola di benvenuto comunque cercato
da su youtube fa troppo ridere
caro grazie alla donazione del 5 euro
per l'italia va beh mi sembra un po
esagerato caro però ti ringrazio si è
molto gentile mi avete sempre detto
questa cosa una volta perché lo copiavo
adesso perché faccio i gol che gli scopi
ha copiato bravissimo comunque io però
l'ho sempre detto che tu hai una
porzione della coppia più di bahia ok
hai una porzione del cervello che da
solo carime me a fare quel sì sì sì sarà
di vernarelli e se non è possibile
tenuta abbia o meno come potevo la prima
ragazzi la pubblico appena finisco qua
perché se però faccio una volta faccio
la aspetta che questo non è un brutto
tiro attenzione madonna come l'ha
imparata in due
posso caricarla e volendo non fate voi
fate voi fate voi in questo importa
tirate mai a volte mamma mi ha fatto una
progressione solo di ignoranza demolito
ognuno balzato l'altro più che un
coccodrillo un elefante ma sono molti
tasking non lo posso fare altro non lo
posso farlo la mamma è rimasta più o
meno latte che brutta la donna ragazzi
ancora da solo di daiwa dei tre a zero
potrebbe rendere così stefano mangia
freddo è appena arrivato il cibo ecco
hanno lasciato nella buca delle lettere
dalla nato veronica sia lì no perché è
bello ti infilano un hamburger dentro la
busta deve essere ben sei un hamburger
un po sottile la piadina ma non note lo
schiacciano a de sica c'ero ho capito
che la cassetta di tutto sporco di
maniera
ecco ti toccano la coerenza non ha
fermato con i nostri ristoranti
buon appetito presse non ci potevo
segnarla anche io prima ho sbagliato
tutto nella mia vita qui rimane lì
rimane ancora lì e figurati quando mais
out
no
ok è girato perché di reno tour bravo
bel gol bravo noteranno ripartendo
esplodendo non ho capito quanto sia
esploso di io sì allora hai trappola
dell'esame che te insieme ai sembra
giusto ha detto ma queste soleti lete e
boom
scusami dito lasciati turbo che ce
l'aveva tranquillo no se la liscia para
gol ci credevo che la diceva ci stavo
credere troppo che l'avrebbe lisciate
l'italiano ragazzi anni ok no sì sì sì
sì sì ci sono sto tiro quasi alla spetta
non si che se l'aspetta non sicura che
rasoterra
voglio bene fdi cardella cavallino
grazie al national des jeux fdj capiva
le winx ma perchè perchè a ben il nuovo
telefilm e può essere non aggiunte le
claudio wings seelie e non l'ho guardato
perché non è il mio genere di sebha
grazzini milan di sempre felice con i
tuoi video grazie caro un abbraccio ti
voglio bene
lupin dieci giorni sulle tradizioni
intorno a meno di 20 anni è vero è una
serie animata c'è un film proprio deve
battere il prossimo vive adele quale
roma l'hanno fatto live action e così il
prossimo live action ghiandaro tagliente
ma per l'aceto un anno e mezzo fa
cantare una recita il criceto bravissimo
tensione bel gol bravo io non posso
segnare prato e tanto lascia lascia no è
troppo vicino scusa è anche gol ma
neanche dice almeno faccio una cosa
sbagliata perché quando io sbaglio deve
essere gol ma dove minchia c'è scritto
ma c'e nel regolamento quando accetti
ray sicily insieme perché non capisci
possa sbagliare senza che prendiamo gol
per fare termini edizioni del gioco
io non capisco perché dobbiamo prendere
gol
gabriele ma ecco vite già comprato da
nokia con loro perché pagare
direttamente e brutto tram andarsene ma
come ha fatto anche se lo stato c'è
stato anche il mio cessino e costato
tutto tirato un calcio al cestino per
vendere meglio la palla non anticipa
tutto in mezzo a tutti mezzo non la
butto più hanno forse si è un milan che
ha steso da te non era bello rabello di
celerità e raga non ci arriva di nuovo
turbo però posso che la volta delle
scatole niente ma saltato due volte ok
scusami blog di mezzo se vuoi per non
averlo forte quello per non rischiarlo
forte ok
esatto io li bel gol anche se si salta
tutti e palo e palo niente neanche il
rimbalzo neanche quello ho accettato nel
regolamento che rimbalzi non ci sono
per quanto vale è una fama incredibile
anch'io di una fame di gol preso solo
traversa di figura quest'area che faremo
palesemente gol era presente nice
e grazie step grazie alla gente va bene
nervatura che abbiamo fatto siamo così
diamo in palio 3 ore e 45 di salò rocket
league
ok non vuol cristina grazie la donation
sarà che lo sbarco in quei mesi arrivo
milioni di like prossima con ibra e
ronaldo ma noi ci proviamo cara come mai
nessuno vuole fare con me la cross bar
io avevo firmato 16 ibra no era riferito
a me perché non solo attraverso quello
effettivamente non l'abbiamo già fatta
questo lo speciale bouquet
va bè ragazzi io chiuderei la live vi
ringrazio per averci seguito mi spiace
che si interrotta mentana certa non so
per questo ci vediamo un bacino a tutti
i ragazzi vediamo domenica domenica
[Risate]
domenica si lega un bacino a tutti
giorgio grazie alla prossima ciao ciao
cari